HASHTAG WARS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
FILE THIS UNDER FUN RAGING.
THE GAME CANDY CRUSH SAGA IS SO
POPULAR IT MADE AN ESTIMATED
$3.5 MILLION A DAY LAST YEAR.
THAT IS A LOT OF DOLLARS.
NOW THE CREATORS OF THE GAME
WERE SOMEHOW-- AND THIS IS THE
RAGEFUL PART-- WERE SOMEHOW ABLE
TO TRADEMARK THE WORD "CANDY."
THAT WAS A TRADEMARK THAT WAS
GRANTED BY THE UNITED STATES
TRADEMARK AND PATENT OFFICE.
ALTHOUGH WE ARE NO LONGER
SUPPOSED TO USE THE WORD CANDY,
(BLEEP) THAT NOISE.
TONIGHT'S HASHTAG IS CANDYBANDS!
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
PUT THAT IN YOUR CANDY HOLE,
KING.COM.
EXAMPLES OF HASHTAG CANDYBANDS
WOULD BE HERSHEY'S KISS, THE
FRUIT STRIPES, THE STROKES I
GET FROM CANDY-INDUCED DIABETES,
THINGS OF THAT NATURE.
I'M GOING TO PUT 60 SECONDS ON
THE CLOCK AND LET US BEGIN.
YES, AL YANKOVIC.
>> EMINEMS!
>> Chris: POINTS!
BRIAN POSEHN.
>> WHATCHAMETALLICA.
>> Chris: POINTS!
AUKERMAN.
>> KENDRICK LAMARS BAR.
>> Chris: VERY MUCH POINTS.
YES, AL YANKOVIC.
>> THE PIXY STIX!
>> Chris: YES, POINTS!
TWO-IN-ONE-- POINTS.
YES, SCOTT AUKERMAN.
>> MIKE AND IKE AND TINA TURNER.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: POINTS.
YES, AL YANKOVIC.
>> ALMOND JOY DIVISION.
>> Chris: OH, YES, WELL DONE,
POINTS.
YES, WEIRD AL.
>> THREE MUSKETEERS FOR FEARS!
>> Chris: POINTS!
BRIAN POSEHN?
(BUZZER)
>> NO! WHAT?
TWIZZLER'S SISTER.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)